the thing is to get really close to that
fear embracing get close to get intimate
with it we hear one thing and we Define
the whole understanding of our fear
based on that one thing someone says to
you in the office you know that they're
going to cut a few people and you don't
even check you don't even know and now
you just made it real and now you're
running with it and you're trying to run
away from it so you're trying to avoid
conversations with your boss you're
trying to avoid any conflict actually
what you need to do is go okay let me
actually discover that fear let me go
intimate with that fear let me ask
myself where's that fear coming from
what am I really scared of am I really
scared of losing my job am I scared of
not having any money what am I really
scared of and when you get to the root I
call it the Y ladder in the book so it's
asking yourself what am I scared of and
then go why am I scared of this so when
you can't ask why any longer you've got
to the answer and that's what you have
to deal with most of us are not dealing
with what we're actually scared of so
that's how you let go if I heard that
review here that in your office that
people are getting cut it's like you
just get scared and panicked but the
question is why am I scared of that am I
scared I've been working hard for six
months am I scared of that because I've
been skipping meetings am I scared of
that because I know my boss will
probably fire me first or am I scared
because I've been performing really well
and I'm expecting a promotion knowing
which one it is it sets you up to build
the path forward not knowing that just
puts you in this Panic frenzy my biggest
fear is disappointing people my biggest
fear is that people will watch one of my
videos will buy my book we'll come to
one of my
seminars or speeches or whatever and
feel like well that was a giant waste of
time I don't know um
ultimately where it comes from but
that's my biggest fear and it's and it's
honestly made me play small
my whole life and the the trick that I
found is that I just need to when I can
recognize it I can do something about it
I think most of the time we play small
by default most of the time we find a
reason why we can't do something and we
justify the reason we believe the reason
so for example if I'm afraid to make
videos
in the beginning it was very afraid to
make videos and I wouldn't make a video
until my friend would come and film it
and I look professional I had to have
the perfect script and if you go back
and watch my first video I did it on
Walt Disney's story and it was filmed
professionally by my friend Mark Drager
shout out to you and uh I had the
perfect script and I was trying to
memorize it and I couldn't memorize
enough and so I was mostly voice over
where I read a script And I memorized a
few lines and then we did b-roll over
over my talking points because I was so
concerned that if I said the wrong thing
then people might be disappointed that's
taken a lot of unwinding to do I used to
with interviews I used to want to know
what the questions were going to be in
advance
because I felt like I want to be able to
give good answers I didn't want to
discipline the audience of whoever you
know if I'm being interviewed on
somebody's show I want I want them to
have a great show I don't want to be a
terrible guest
you know I want I want them to feel like
this was really valuable and that I
shared my best information and knowledge
and gave Great Value to Their audience
and so I always wanted to know what
questions do you want to have Evan
answer or have me answer that ended up
being a
mistake because when I knew the
questions I could give good information
but it it was almost robotic because the
answers were rehearsed
where what I've learned is it's much
more about the emotion than it is about
the exact words people remember how you
make them feel Maya Angelou right people
will remember how you make them feel and
if everything is memorized and perfect
and scripted then the feeling isn't
there because you're so worried about
memorizing and seeing the exact right
word that then there's no emotion there
there's no emotion in what you're saying
and what you're creating what you're
producing then it's not going to move
anybody to any kind of action
and that took a lot of unwinding to do
to be honest and it led me to the point
where whenever I can catch it it's like
how do you get through it whenever you
can catch it
take the action that would make you
proud
so this is you know a decade plus of me
unwinding this and taking slow progress
in action and hopefully you can get
there a lot faster by even just
recognizing that as a problem and
watching videos like this but I did a
couple things so anytime you can catch
it you take the action to make you proud
so
why do I want to have all the questions
in advance of an interview well The
Logical story in my head is because I
want to give a lot of value to the
audience underneath that is the fear
that I'm going to disappoint them oh
it's showing up again okay so now I have
to take corrective action which is I
don't want to have any questions in
advance which freaked me out right like
but what if x happens
it freaked me out because it freaked me
out I had to go off and do it you know
you start to teach yourself are you the
kind of person who does the things that
freak you out or not
I don't think I had any total train
wrecks or total disasters
but I end up making everything so much
stronger so much better and so much more
fun too that I could just be myself and
show up and answer questions and have a
much better time with the host than than
otherwise than me being stressed out
about getting the right right answers
done all the time on the flip side for
doing interviews
I would always stress out too about
disappointing the guests and
disappointing the audience and feeling
like I I mean I would stress out I think
about having Tony Robbins on the channel
or Matthew McConaughey on the channel or
all the people that I've interviewed on
the channel
honestly the beginning maybe a week
leading up to it I'd be I'd be stressed
out
researching memorizing asking myself
what questions I want to ask running the
story over and over and over and over
and over and over again in my mind in my
head just a wreck I was a total wreck
that's all I could focus on because I
was so stressed out about doing a good
interview and getting their story out
and giving value to them and to you guys
and not you know the fear underneath
that is disappointing anyone's
disappoint Tony I didn't want to
disappoint you guys in the audience and
the breaking of that came down to you
know what it's going to be a lot better
if it's more natural it doesn't mean I
stopped doing research but my solution
has been
I find an angle that I want to pull on I
find the thread that I want to pull on
and once I find that thread I stop
stressing and worrying about the
interview
so yesterday I had Alex hermosi on my
channel and we did an Instagram live and
I don't know Alex super well we've
connected a little bit on on DMS on
Instagram but I've never done a
interview never haven't met him yet in
person at least at the time of this
recording and I watched some of his
videos and I looked at his story and I
found the angle that I wanted to to go
down I wanted I found the thread I
wanted to pull on and once I did that I
stopped researching the story and now I
can get to within a couple hours
of researching somebody knowing what I
want to talk to them about
and where we can find our conversation
will be different than others and and I
still I still stress out before an
interview
before I'm I'm interviewing somebody
but it's now maybe an hour you know it's
it's 45 minutes or an hour of stressing
out as opposed to a week
I've played small my whole life based
off of this fear of disappointing other
people who's gonna see me fail and and
are they gonna feel like they wasted
their time or money
and as a result
it's led to a much
smaller life and lower impact than what
I'm capable of doing
and similar for you you know you've got
fears and insecurities and doubts and
worried about judgment or losing love or
whatever it is and it's keeping you
small and the point of that is not to
beat yourself up it's not to beat myself
up and say oh wow I suck now because I'm
not I'm not doing it it's to realize hey
I've still got a long life ahead you've
still got so many years ahead of you to
live the life that you wanted to have a
big impact and to build the business
that you want to build you you can still
do all of that and recognizing what your
biggest fear is
will allow you to tackle it will allow
you to stop listening to the reasons
right reasons in your head as to why you
can't do something but underneath that
is just fear you're not going to believe
a stupid reason right you're a smart
person so you're going to believe really
smart reasons so our brain comes up with
really smart reasons why we can't do
something right oh I can't make YouTube
videos because I don't have the right
gear and the right camera and the right
phone and the the Right microphone and
the right speech and what's my topic
going to be and what's the thumbnail
going to be and I don't know editing yet
and I don't know what to call it I don't
know the description and do tags still
work and you spend all this time
researching and over analyzing over
stressing because you want it to be
perfect and you've trained yourself that
these are all really value valid reasons
until you believe it but underneath all
of that is really just fear
your fear of it not working you're free
you're afraid of that it will work and
who will see it you're free that it
won't work and people won't see it
you're afraid of being judged you're
afraid of looking a certain way it's
just fear it's just fear the reason why
you're not doing the thing that you want
to do you have you have goals you have
an ambition you have a mission you have
a vision for what you want to create and
the reason why you're not doing is
because you're afraid you're afraid of
something
and we've convinced ourselves with
logical reasons why you can't do it but
really you're just afraid underneath all
of that is just fear and if you can
tackle the fear all of a sudden the
logical reasons go away
because underneath it was just fear you
could start your YouTube video you could
I mean I'm sitting here in my car on my
phone while Nina's in Costco look see
Nina's in Costco I'm sitting in the
parking lot
making this video
you know it's just fear
fear and so when you can catch what the
thing is that you're afraid of
that fear
I don't think that it goes away it just
shows up in in bigger versions of it so
I'm still afraid of disappointing people
but it's just now on a bigger scale the
things that you know doing an interview
I'm not as afraid of anymore
interviewing others I'm not as afraid of
anymore even this like filming in public
I used to be terrified of doing this I'm
filming in public like there's like
people oh I'm gonna show you because
they're looking at me they're people are
packing up their cars and unloading
their groceries and I would always judge
and worry like oh if I'm gonna do
something outside it should be like
we're at the back of the parking lot
because what do people walk past me and
they're judging me and they're looking
at me I I could never have done this you
know however many years ago and now
we're here so once you conquer that fear
it allows you to keep doing that same
thing but the same fear shows up on a
bigger scale
so I'm not as afraid to do an interview
but I'm afraid to do interview on a
bigger show or I'm afraid to go off and
and speak on a giant stage and the trick
is to catch the fear not believe the
excuse or the reasons why we can't do
that thing
and teach yourself that you become the
person who does the things that are
scary
your entire great life is on the other
side of your fears everything that you
want out of life and the impact you want
to have and the business you want to
build the money you want to make is on
the other side of you taking on those
fears because you've got the heart
you've got the passion you've got the
soul you've got the desire to serve
you've got it you've got it all
you're just afraid and that's normal and
that's okay
the trick is to not succumb to the fears
to rise up to them to meet them head on
and go build the life that you want
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
at 18 I was really fortunate when I met
a monk and this monk was invited to
speak and I kind of just went because
one of my friends forced me to at that
time I was listening to CEOs and
entrepreneurs and business people and
marketers who who I thought that's what
I was aspiring to be like and then I
hear this Monk
and he captivated me like no one had
ever captivated me before it was like
staring at the most beautiful woman on
the planet you know I was completely
fixated on him and his message see we
live in Echo Chambers we're just
surrounded by the same thinking how
often do you bump into a monk you know
it just doesn't happen you don't have no
one has a dinner party and goes oh yeah
we just invited the monk you know from
town like the local monk like no one
ever does that and so we meet people who
are just like us most of the time
and we talk about this in business all
the time if you want to be a billionaire
spend time with billionaires if you want
to be a millionaire spend time with
millionaires if you want to be a tech
startup spend time with you know that's
that's the common rhetoric that we hear
all the time but what if you want to
find a purpose and master the mind
there's no one better than a monk who's
mastered the mind so so for me the first
step is just opening yourself up to new
experiences and new Role Models because
most of us can't see ourselves
in people so then we try and fit
ourselves into the boxes that we do see
and and I mean there's this beautiful
quote that I I've been saying it
everywhere and I wish I wrote it but I
didn't so it's by a philosopher and
writer named Cooley and he said that
today I'm not what I think I am I'm not
what you think I am I am what I think
you think I am
right and just let that blow your mind
for a moment it's uh it's so powerful
I'm not what I think I am I'm not what
you think I am I am what I think you
think I am so we live in this perception
of a perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think I should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks I should achieve
while you're living in that bubble in
that Echo chamber
getting to what you really want to do is
impossible because maybe that just
doesn't fit and I think so many people
feel that way today that they don't fit
into the current education system they
don't fit with the three or four or five
careers that your tour exist
so that process of self-excavation and
actualization first requires being
exposed you can't be what you can't see
if I never saw a monk I would never have
wanted to be a monk if I never meet a
billionaire I wouldn't want to be one
because I wouldn't know what that feels
like I don't know what it looks like I
don't know what it takes
and and I think that's the biggest
challenge of our society that we're not
exposed so that's the first step being
exposed to Unique experiences and Role
Models second step is finding that
experience or role model that you're
passionate about and exactly like you
said taking it seriously Shadow their
network with them spend time with them
observe them even from afar it takes
that observation being addicted to
observing that person's lifestyle
and then the third step is going yes or
no does that work for me not everyone
who's going to go off and become a monk
is going to feel like the way I did and
that's cool
but not everyone is going to go and
follow and Shadow a billionaire and go
that's exactly the lifestyle I want they
may want the result but do they want the
hard work that goes with it and so for
me that's the third step it's observing
focusing shadowing getting as close to
the process of that individual and then
going yes or no do I want that process
not do I want the result everyone wants
to be that monk who's fully enlightened
you know can walk through as an
incredible aura that people just
gravitate towards but when you realize
he has to wake up at 2AM every day and
sleeps about four to six hours you're
like ah you know I don't want to do that
that doesn't sound like me in the middle
of 2009 he was the software engineer
that no one wanted to hire he had 12
years of experience at Yahoo but he was
rejected by Facebook and then rejected
by Twitter he'd been to a great
University he had a great CV but he
decided to team up with one of his
alumni members at Yahoo and started to
create an app and focus on the startup
space in five years time he sold that
app for 19 billion dollars to Facebook
believe it or not that was Brian Acton
the co-founder of WhatsApp when he was
rejected from Facebook he said it was a
great opportunity to connect with some
fantastic people I look forward to
Life's next adventure when he was
rejected by Twitter he responded by
saying worked out it was quite a long
commute it's so interesting to see that
someone rejected from two of the top
internet companies actually responded
with humor and actually responded with
positivity this lady was diagnosed with
clinical depression her marriage had
failed and she was jobless with a
dependent child she was on a four hour
delayed train journey from Manchester to
London when she came up with this idea
and she started to write this book about
this Wizard and as she started writing
she then finished her manuscript took it
to 12 Publishers and was rejected by all
12. believe it or not that's JK Rowling
this man watched his first company
crumble he was a Harvard University
Dropout and his first company's demo
didn't even work he went on to build
Microsoft his name's Bill Gates
therefore failure is just a sign that we
need to widen our scope we need to be
ready and build ourselves up for the
next level actually what we end up
achieving is far greater than what we'd
envisioned for ourselves and this divine
plan this orchestration can't be
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we
just settle we just accept what we
thought was our goal what we thought we
were chasing but actually I've noticed
that when you don't get there later down
the line you look back and you reflect
and realize that what you've gained is
so much greater failures are only
failures when we don't learn from them
because when we learn from them they
become lessons and we actually
extrapolate all of these teachings and
actually get more insight into how we
can improve the way we work and how we
can actually drive with a different
energy the challenge we have is that we
only talk about people's failures when
they succeed and that's why they become
this taboo or we feel like their
failures never happened we need to share
these stories earlier we need to bring
out these stories and experiences on the
journey so that people who are on the
journey can actually follow in those
footsteps and that's why Steve Jobs said
you can't connect the dots moving
forward you only can when you're looking
backwards Fred Smith was an
undergraduate at Yale University in
1965. as part of his coursework he wrote
an economics paper exploring the
transportation of goods in the United
States it's how things get delivered to
you and me he found that shippers were
transporting large packages and items
either via truck or through passenger
airplanes he thought he had a more
efficient method he wrote a last minute
paper as you do about how a company
transporting small items via plane would
be a much better business model because
he was rushed he never really got around
to explaining in the paper how that
company would run and he ended up
getting a c the funny thing is he still
didn't give up and in 1971 he actually
launched the company he was speaking
about but within three years of founding
the company Federal Express as it was
called was actually on the verge of
bankruptcy they were losing over a
million a month that was because of
rising fuel costs competitors in the
same market and at its Zenith it was
only worth about five thousand dollars
Smith even made a final pitch to General
Dynamics hoping for more funding and it
was rejected most people at this point
probably would have just shut down
rejection the grade C losing a million a
month but Fred Smith had different ideas
Smith actually ended up flying to Las
Vegas that weekend with all of what the
company had the five thousand dollars
the Monday morning after the company had
32 000 thanks to his Blackjack skills
that money made it possible to cover
fuel costs for just a few days more soon
after the company was able to raise
significant funds he went around to
multiple places to find sponsors
investors people that believed in what
he was trying to achieve as a service
the amazing thing is that he was
creating a company that we all know
today it's called FedEx it now operates
in over 220 countries and has an annual
revenue of over 45 billion dollars the
interesting lesson that we can learn
here is that there were countless
occasions in Fred Smith's life where he
could have said that's it it's not
working for me he could have stopped
when he got that c for the paper he
could have stopped when he was losing a
million a month he could have even
stopped when he finally only had enough
to just last a few more days but he
believed in his vision he had belief he
had conviction about his idea and the
process and the service that he was
creating and that's the lesson here if
you really want to achieve something
you'll find a way and if you don't
you'll find excuses now it's incredible
that we root for underdogs it's
incredible that we want underdogs to win
why because we're used to wanting our
team to win we're used to wanting the
best to win we're used to wanting to
associate ourselves with people who are
successful right we never go oh yeah I
know someone who plays for that really
bad team like we don't say that right we
say things like oh I know someone who
plays with that really good team I know
someone who was MVP I know someone who's
the son or the daughter of the MVP we
try and Associate or link ourselves to
success and when we do that it in turn
makes us feel more successful it's one
of the reasons why when your team wins
you say we won right you say we won but
when someone asks you oh how did your
team do and if they lost that day you
say they lost you rarely say we lost
it's incredible how psychologically we
distance ourselves from failure and we
close and or liken ourselves to success
but the exception to that rule is the
underdog we all get excited by
underdoctors we all get motivated by
underdogs we feel completely enamored by
the story of the underdog prashan
underdogs are just simple-minded they
don't have expectations and don't have
anything to prove to anybody and
Prashant you've just hit the nail on the
head that's the principle I'm trying to
get across actually we should play like
Champions and train like underdogs why
because the underdog Works in a way not
worrying about what anybody else thinks
or believes that gives you an edge it
gives you a phenomenal Advantage when
you're not actually worried about what
will people say when you're not
concerned by am I going to fail am I
going to look worse is what I'm doing
not going to succeed as an underdog you
don't let those things Cloud your mind
you can focus in on the task at hand see
when we become successful even as
underdogs if we've risen to success the
biggest enemy of that success the
biggest Achilles heel the biggest thing
that can trip us up is not reconnecting
to that feeling of an underdog so no
matter how much success you've achieved
no matter where you are always remind
yourself the mindset of an underdog is
the mindset that nurtures talent that
nurtures success that harnesses your
true potential what's the impact that
you want to have on the world
I think you've you've you've said it so
beautifully so many times and shared my
vision which is wonderful and it's
wonderful to know that we share the same
thing it's making wisdom go viral
there's an incredible study in 2017 that
said the most successful people in the
world
healthy wealthy and wise
choose education over entertainment
the impact I want to have on the world
is I want to transform and revolutionize
the entertainment industry
so that it becomes educational without
anyone knowing so it's still completely
entertaining it's still like watching
Netflix but you're learning about human
behavior the Mind neuroscience and
everything without even knowing you are
to me that's the greatest win that we
can have for our society how many people
are going to quit watching Netflix and
reading a book every night I don't know
but if we can make that book come to
life on Netflix that's going to change
the world because that's what people are
going to consume so for so long media
has been used to numb people to to
switch people off if we can use it to
excite Elevate and Enlighten people not
by just not by like the cheesy way of
like oh let's follow someone through
their journey of Enlightenment it's not
like that kind of stuff I mean like
really entertaining programming
where you can learn by being entertained
at the same time if I can do that by
changing the the most powerful industry
in the world then I will feel that I've
had some some whatever impact
because that way I think we'll reach the
world without having to get everyone to
change their habits too much
my thing is how do we meet people where
they are
and and really deliver a message and a
powerful
expression of love and to me that's the
highest form of compassion the highest
form of empathy love and compassion
is to meet people where they already are
rather than expecting them to change
he tell you about this girl called Cleo
I think you might know someone like her
too she had the dream of becoming a
model she said she was going to move to
LA to pursue it seriously she took care
of herself at least her body well
someone told me she did ads for L'Oreal
she had so many followers on Instagram
who all loved her within a minute of her
posting a picture there would be
hundreds and hundreds of comments all
telling her how beautiful she was how
good she looked comment after comment
light after like she was a real
Entertainer she was always making
everyone laugh I remember every guy
wanted her number
to herself she just had this infectious
energy
got along with everyone she was always
the life of the party she was never seen
in the same outfit twice boxes and boxes
of Amazon Prime on Instagram she was the
perfect girl with the perfect life the
perfect world with the perfect guys
nothing's perfect right it seemed like
she was always having the best time with
her friends always traveling new
experiences and so many great stories to
share until people started to notice
think she lived like two lives no one
really knew her inside she had everyone
to text but no one to talk to everyone
to follow but no one to walk with when
the phone was up her world was a stage
but it was down a reality came she had
an invite to every event but still felt
lonely
friends in the world but still fell no
one really knows me she was going
through pain but never showed that side
it was something she hid from the world
or maybe we just never asked she had
masked her sadness with what looked like
the ideal life she was always Flying
high in the air or felt low inside her
inbox was always full but she felt empty
within she was happy on the outside but
struggling with depression and anxiety
she had an addiction that everyone
called the lifestyle but she was
struggling with mental health but people
were just occupied by her physical
appearance
sadness people think depression is
crying people think depression is being
quiet depression is when we smile but we
want to cry it's when we talk but we
want to be quiet it's when we pretend
like we're happy
and not
oppression is not always obvious she
drank to drown her pain but
let them swim
she was sick of crying tired of trying
smiling but inside she was dying it's
amazing how we can think we know someone
and still not know them at all I don't
think we understand how stressful it is
to explain what's going on in your head
when you don't even understand yourself
we use filters to lighten our photos
whilst we carry the heavy weight of
stress remember it's okay to have
highlight reels but make sure someone
knows how you really feel it's okay to
use FaceTime but make sure you spend
quality time face to face it's okay to
have followers but make sure you have
true friends don't live for the approval
of others document the moments you're
most in love with yourself not just the
moments you think people will love the
most when someone doesn't post for a few
days we ask if they're okay when someone
posts every day a we assume they are
tell people you love them be a
trustworthy friend tell them that they
matter tell them that they've survived a
lot and they're ready to thrive now
people who care will ask how you're
doing people who love you will wait till
you tell the truth and that's why Robin
Williams said I used to think that the
worst thing in life was to end up alone
it's not the worst thing in life is to
end up with people who make you feel
alone something that happens is you have
to surround yourself by peers in a space
too who understand you and don't see you
as competition and that's really hard
and it's like a fine line I genuinely
believe that collaboration wins always
so I my whole approach to most things
has always been hey I want to
collaborate with you whether I'm bigger
on social media or smaller on social
media I'm just like I just want to work
together because I think that's going to
win long term for all of us both not
just in terms of success in numbers but
more in terms of I want to be friends
with you and so I reach out regularly to
people that I admire in different ways
and I reach out to them and say hey I'd
love to get to know you I'd love to
learn from you I'd love to connect I'd
love to be a friend like not I'd love to
for you to teach me how you do this and
if that comes naturally from that
relationship amazing if it never evolves
into that I've just got a great friend
who now gets me so I try and make
friends in two areas one is in an area
of people who understand my life because
I feel the conversations you can have
with someone who does exactly what you
do are just so great because they
already get you right and uh someone
that I had on my podcast lately her name
is Lily Singh Superwoman she's become a
recent friend she's been incredibly and
is incredibly successful on social media
she's using a platform for doing amazing
good in the world and she was someone I
reached out to because I was just like
hey like you've been doing all of this
for a while you start on YouTube a lot
longer than I did and I would just love
to connect from you and hear from you
and she's become an incredible friend
and we've just been sharing ideas and
learning together and it's like that
relationship's awesome and then at the
same time I'm trying to find people who
are not in media so I still have
friendships with the monks back in India
and I just spent January in India for a
month I was meditating again for for
roughly about 21 days and I have them in
my life because they remind me of like
the roots and they remind me of the
truths that bring me back
so I kind of like both I love people who
totally get my space and usually those
are people I reach out to and then I
love having my roots down so most of my
inner circle now is from people I've
reached out to or they become people
who've been reaching out to me for a
long long time and have been
consistently reaching out to me asking
for nothing the challenge is that we
think
things
come with emotions feelings we think
things come with feelings and emotions
and guess what they don't so if you
chase money well they might for a moment
right or they won't I don't think they
even do it's such a false sense of
feeling I don't maybe for a moment but
it's so short-lived that it's it's not
even worth counting almost so it's like
when you when you think that I'm chasing
money guess what you will get money yep
and that's great money is really
important and money is a really
important resource but guess what money
is not now Gonna Fill that Gap that void
that feeling that emotion that you're
missing in your life what are most
people missing we're missing a deep
sense of love I think I think the
biggest need in the world as we've heard
many times before from all the ancient
texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling a false sense of Love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing What We crave
in life is what we did or didn't get
from our parents what our parents did
give us is what we continue to Crave or
what they didn't give us is what we
continue to Crave so you'll find that
most people's love languages that they
chase are things that their parents
didn't give them so if their parents
didn't give them time they now crave
everyone's time if their parents didn't
give them gifts they'd crave gifts if
their parents didn't give them acts of
service they're craving those acts of
service so it's because of our childhood
and if we don't learn to process all of
that experience which most people never
get the time to do and I empathize with
that because I've had to go through that
I've seen me repeating my parents
patterns I've seen the thing you were
craving so I would crave a big thing for
me was I would crave surprises and gifts
because that's your thing yeah that's my
did your parents not do that for you no
they did my mom did a lot of it that's
why you're still crazy correct so my mom
would always every year on my birthday
she'd always surprise me with the one
thing I wanted and I wasn't spoiled
growing up I didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a Power Rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something video game yeah the thing
is you want as a kid right and she would
always surprise me with that and that
became so deep rooted now I'll give you
an example when I then married my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're gonna do the same thing totally
and so now you can do that no because
I'm expecting my wife to be like my mom
in the sense of I expected a surprise or
show me love in the same way and she
doesn't know that she's not a mind
reader I can't explain expected to know
that so it took communication it took
time for me to explain that so anyway I
think that's where it stems from that
desire it doesn't come from any you can
say it comes from society and education
of course it does but I think the
deepest place it comes is what your
parents did or didn't give you that's
that's what it comes from a young boy
once asked his teacher what's the
difference between I like you and I love
you the teacher beautifully answered
well it's like a flower if you like a
flower you pluck it but if you love a
flower you water it and nurture it daily
and watch it grow there is such a thin
line between like and love and because
of it we make so many mistakes in our
relationships when we want something in
the moment we take it and don't think
any further we do whatever we want to
get that feeling of pleasure not
realizing that we're neither Satisfied
by that pleasure and nor will that thing
last when we pluck a flower not only
will that flower die but we can't
experience it for any longer than that
moment when you water it and take care
of it daily you can experience it
forever we've been wired towards an
instant gratification instant pleasure
mindset all of the adverts that we see
whether they're online or offline are
geared to driving us towards making
instant decisions for instant Promises
of pleasure the catch is not only does
that instant pleasure not satisfy us the
feeling doesn't last we're so used to
seeing all the strap lines and headlines
on the internet learn this language in
five minutes get the ideal body in 10
minutes a day become a millionaire in 12
months now all of these sound brilliant
right the problem is they're not real
they're not true they're false promises
the reason why it works is because it
appeals to one of the most basic human
desires situational Improvement without
major resource investment of course you
can pick up a few words in another
language or shed a few pounds of weight
if that was your goal or maybe you will
make a little bit more money but real
knowledge real awareness real Fitness
real business all of these things take
time real relationships real connection
real purpose takes time naturally the
internet headlines focus on the short
term instead of the long term because
most of us would never click on
something if it said learn a language in
five years with dedicated daily practice
we wouldn't click on something that said
here is the one hour workout that you
need to do every single day and we
wouldn't click on the one that said if
you want to be a millionaire here are
the 10 failures that you'll go through
in year one how broke you might be by
year three and you may not even make it
by year nine the important lesson here
is if you want meaning if you want
purpose if you want fulfillment those
things take time you talked about the
fear of fear and how you had to learn to
let go of your fear of fear what does
that actually mean letting go of the
fear of fear yeah so I talk about how we
fear the wrong things
what do we fear so most of us are
fearful of how our friends are reacting
what's happening on social media and
what's the random bit of news that we
heard none of it is fact-based that's
one of the biggest issues the worry base
it's worry based and it's also
imagination based so we become fiction
writers we've all watched too many
movies now we start writing these
beautiful movies in our head we're not
beautiful scary movies in our head of
what may happen so our imagination and
Seneca said it best we suffer twice one
in reality and one in imagination but we
suffer twice and this is what actually
happens to us telling the story we
continue to tell totally now there's
this incredible study in the book that I
have to talk about so they took monks
and they took non-months and they
competed against each other against each
other literally so they put this play
experience Heat
and so
what is the
the not this plate now this plate heats
up gradually softly and then at one
point it gets really hot for 10 seconds
then it cools down and so what happened
is that when the non-months touched it
the anxiety and pressure and stress in
their brain just triggered straight away
even though it wasn't that hot it wasn't
hot it was heating but it wasn't hard to
do anything major to you but the anxiety
and stress in imagination or in
anticipation went through the roof in
the non-monks now this is what's
fascinating when the monks touched it
they showed that it didn't feel anything
as it Rose but as it got to its highest
they felt physical pain but they showed
no trigger of emotional pain because
they did not assign any emotional
element to that pain so my point with
that is you can look at the news right
now and you can get scared straight away
and get incomplete freeze mode feeling
stuck paralyzed whatever it is because
what you're now doing is you're creating
a story of what's going to happen and
that story you can cause sickness in
yourself
not actually the reality that the facts
of the disease hitting you or something
happening physically to you totally and
that story again can be used positively
so your story may actually be true
but if it's going to be true now you can
prepare and that shifts you away from
being scared because now you're
preparing yes and so the real confident
because you're prepared exactly and so
we should be shifting our fear energy
into preparation energy because what
fear does is it keeps you locked there
right we just feel stuck I'll give you
an example when you were preparing for
big games when you used to play in the
NFL right and you're playing American
football against some of the biggest
athletes in the world it's like you can
either sit down and be scared that
you're going to play this game on the
weekend or you can prepare and your
confidence is in the preparation so when
people go how do I feel confident right
now
are you preparing are you put in the
Reps how are you putting the reps are
you building your immunity are you
taking your vitamins are you doing lots
of water are you drinking lots of water
are you taking the steps that are needed
to prepare for whatever's coming you
will feel more confident that way yeah
there are sometimes when I'm with a
social media person who says something
really useful for my roots and there's
someone downstairs and they say
something else and there's a great story
actually about when the prime minister
of India Modi he visited Facebook and
Mark Zuckerberg interviewed him at
Facebook at the headquarters and Mark
Zuckerberg told a story he said that
when he was struggling with the
direction of Facebook in 2009 he went up
to his mentor to ask a question now smog
Zuckerberg's Mentor happened to be Steve
Jobs and so he went after Steve Jobs and
he said Steve I'm struggling with the
direction of Facebook what do I do
and at that time you know I mean Steve
Jobs is Steve Jobs he could have said
anything and it would have made sense
but you know he could have said go and
meet a venture capitalist he could have
said go and be an investor he could have
said go and meet a tech company he could
have said I'll tell you what to do
instead he said I think you need to go
to India and spend some time in an
ashram a monastery in India with monks
he goes when you do that you'll find the
answer of what you want to do
and to me that is exactly why the people
that are most successful in this world
are successful because they surround
themselves with people who have
differing beliefs
and MIT did a reset study on this they
found that people who are more
Innovative and creative in an
organization new people who didn't know
each other so when you know people who
all know each other you end up with the
same answer the same belief and
confirmation bias exists and you just
keep building that Echo chamber whereas
if you've got two people who don't agree
and you get a checking system then you
can trust your gut and go with what you
believe so I think I try and move away
from having people around me and it's
not just Yes Men or yes women it's about
it's not just about that it's about
building a circle of people like you
said that want different things for you
and knowing what they want for you so
when I'm with my mum all my mom cares
about is my health right my mom does not
care how successful I am how many videos
how many people I help even that that my
mom will get over that she's like how's
your health are you taking care of
yourself are you sleeping well are you
eating well like that's my mom and it's
like if I go and I measure everything
most of that that's wrong but if I know
that that's what my mom wants for me
that's beautiful that's what I get from
her and she'll take care of that and the
same you know everyone plays a different
role in your life don't expect everyone
to play the role you want and don't
expect everyone to play the same role
recognize that everyone's playing their
role in your life and let them play it
that's what makes a good movie if
everyone played the same role in the
movie it'd be boring very boring right
every day we recharge our phones but we
forget to recharge ourselves let's just
say we slept well the night before which
means we start our day with a hundred
percent charge when we wake up in the
morning we roll over and 80 of us check
our smartphones before we brush our
teeth we scroll through social media we
browse through emails that takes away 10
of our energy let's say we now have 90
charge left we then commute to work we
spend our day in the office in meetings
interacting with colleagues finishing
off projects and assignments we now have
40 charge left on the way home we
commute through traffic or on the train
and that takes away another let's say 10
we now have 30 percent charge left we
come home and switch on Netflix talk to
someone about what our day was like and
sometimes we lose and another 10 percent
we now have twenty percent charge left
at twenty percent on our phones usually
the charge bar goes red we get an alert
we get a message that tells us that we
only have twenty percent battery left
the question is do we notice when our
charge is at twenty percent or ten
percent there are always signs from our
bodies our brains our minds but are we
tuned in one of the best things we can
do to recharge is to exercise the
hardest part of any workout is actually
the 15 minutes leading up to it we come
up with 15 reasons why we don't want to
sweat and we change our mind 15
different times CNN reports that when
you work out your brain creates more
serotonin which sends messages to your
nervous system of happiness and
well-being working out for 30 to 40
minutes every day can recharge our
battery by 20 meditation is incredible
way to recharge our batteries exactly
what the gym does for the body
meditation can do for the Mind
meditation gives us downtime physically
mentally emotionally and spiritually
meditation also directly impacts your
entire nervous system by reducing your
body's Productions of stress related
chemicals such as cortisol meditation is
a great way to recharge and can take you
back up 20 we've all heard about
incredible morning routines but the one
thing that can make a huge difference to
your recharge is your evening routine 35
percent of us are not getting the
recommended seven hours of sleep per
night remember every body and mind is
different make sure you find the amount
of time you need to get that serious
battery recharge and the 75-year study
by Harvard found that beyond anything
the real sense check for happiness and
meaning in life was relationships
connections interactions with depth that
are fulfilling and full of joy making
time for deep meaningful interactions
every day can give the recharge our
battery seriously needs what if we've
recharged ourselves as much as we
recharge our phones because if we don't
we'll end up like one of our phones in
the bottom of some drawer in our home
here's the shocking truth about
loneliness
this is why we need to take it more
seriously surveys show one out of three
adults are lonely and the health impacts
of loneliness are shocking Studies have
shown that people who are lonely are 50
more likely to die before their time
researchers show that loneliness is as
damaging to our health as not smoking
one not two but 15 cigarettes per day
only around half of Americans say they
have meaningful face-to-face
interactions with a loved one family or
friend every single day members of
Generation Z say they are the loneliest
generation and experience more health
problems as a result of it loneliness
was also linked with less physical
activity compulsive use of digital
technology and not being able to share
our problems with others in a study of
20 000 adults 54 say that they don't
know one person that knows them well
additionally 56 percent of people said
that the people they'd surround
themselves with are not necessarily with
them and approximately 40 percent said
that they lack companionship don't have
meaningful relationships and feel
isolated all of us have been in the
crowd that felt lonely all of us have
been invited to a party but wanted to
leave all of us have likes on social
media but don't feel loved in real life
so many of us can get comments on our
posts but can't get a friend to call us
back loneliness is real so here's what
we have to do after studying over 2 500
consumers over six years research found
that people that see material
possessions as a sign of success felt
more lonely investing our money in
experience rather than things is a great
way of breaking the loneliness and
materialism cycle schedule a time each
day to talk to a friend take a class to
learn something new
volunteer to deepen your sense of
purpose spend time with people who look
more like your future than your past the
mental health charity mind decides two
factors that towards loneliness
someone either not having enough social
contact
or more interestingly being surrounded
by people but not feeling understood
loved or cared for notice it's not just
being around people but being understood
it's not just being invited and present
but feeling like you're contributed
loneliness really comes then from a lack
of significance or lack of worth and
what you bring to the table and what
value you truly offer lonely is not
being alone it
feeling that no one loves you so start
by loving yourself I read an incredible
study that changed the way I create and
think and it said that the human mind
can't be logical and creative at the
same time
how many of you have ever walked from a
highly creative brainstorm where you
were filled with passion and then had to
talk about numbers and business and
right it's tough right anyone ever found
that quite difficult it's quite
challenging and the mind's like trying
to run from one side of the brain to the
other side of the brain so what I do is
I create in depth so I go really deep
into my creation and then I go really
deep into everything else that I have to
do so before I went to India I created
my content in advance
and so when I was in India I was able to
really switch off
so the beauty of being able to be in
India for 21 or 30 days or wherever I am
in the world for that matter I'm then
not having to think of creativity as
stress or pressure I'm able to do
creativity as a form of passion and
service and so when I was in India I was
able to not look at Instagram I was able
to not look at Facebook I was able to
completely switch off for 21 days when I
was there earlier in January and I
started my year in the way I wanted to
so I was meditating for eight hours a
day I was spending time with my teachers
who are mind-blowing and incredible and
trying to learn from them and taking
knowledge and wisdom from them and
continuously praying to be of more
service this year and make a difference
this year so that's how I chose to spend
my January and I had so many people
saying to me they were just like Jay
it's January things are going well in
your career how can you take 21 days off
right that pressure that noise I feel
like things are going good for you how
can you take time off I was like things
are going good because I'm doing this
right like you know I had one of my
teachers that has kept saying to me for
years he goes if you want to move three
steps forward do you have to go three
steps deep
and so if I'm not going forward I know
it's because I haven't gone deep so for
me that's a big priority for me and
that's what I try and do when I'm you
know I try and do that every day but I
also believe in immersive experiences
so a lot of us today we live in this
world which is like 10 minutes a day do
it for 10 minutes today everything will
be great and that is great there's
nothing wrong with that but imagine you
spent
with a boy or a girl your partner
whoever was someone that you just
started dating imagine you spent 10
minutes a day with them
how long would it take you to figure out
whether you wanted to fall in love with
them or not
probably a long time
away with someone you know whether you
like them or not and meditation
mindfulness all these habits are the
same the more you immerse yourself
the more you get an experience that
stays with you the more that you can
live with that experience and keep going
back to it for 10 minutes a day so I
really believe in immersive experiences
I love the 10 minute a day advice but I
also deeply believe in having an deep
immersive
absorbed experience
that completely takes over your whole
body mind and soul we're wired for
generosity but we're educated for greed
I think I decided to you two years ago
when I was on the podcast it's like and
when I said that and the statement and
so true we're wired for generosity but
we're educated for greed because what
happens is when we're kids
you see kids you want to share God their
way they want to share part of my candy
bar whatever right yeah and then as we
get older we're told that there's less
and this is what the key is as we get
older we're told there are finite
numbers of how many kids get made onto
the basketball or baseball team yes
we're told there's a finite number of
college bases we're told there's a
finite number of how many tickets there
are we're told there's a finite number
of people that are successful guess what
in the theater of Happiness there are
infinite and unlimited seats and there
is a sea with your name on it there is a
c with your name on it in the theater of
Dreams in the theater of happiness but
you think that because you think that
there are only a hundred people allowed
in that if someone else makes it before
you that you don't get in and guess what
is there a cap on how many billionaires
there are in the world no no is there a
cap and how many millionaires around the
world no is there a cap on how many
happy people there are in the world no
and that's why I really am encouraging
Forbes I want Forbes forget printing on
richness
service list we should do that we should
do this loving the most in the world wow
it'll be competition based yeah yeah
sure I gave more than you get and that's
why it should be serviced based on time
energy and money because we should start
showing how much time people give how
much energy people give Mother Teresa I
don't think she gave any money to her
Charities right but you get out of time
and energy yeah you know you look at all
the people who made a change in the
world Martin Luther King Gandhi like
they may not have given a lot of money
to stuff yeah they gave time and energy
you don't have to give resources but
your resourcefulness your love your love
them your focus your attention your
compassion love that uh you know
resourcefulness of the of the heart not
of the wallet I think I love that and
you don't need to have a lot of money to
make a big impact you don't there's and
and this is the training see we've been
educated for greed because we've been
told everything's Limited
there's limited number of this limited
number of this number and every time you
play in numbers and I think it was Bob
Marley who said it but every time you
play in numbers you'll always be
dissatisfied because guess what
someone's always got money someone's
always gonna have more I was speaking to
a friend recently and and it's me and
and this friend was telling me that he
um you know bought a home which is very
expensive very very expensive and he
went to a party at someone else's house
and he told me that when he was getting
a tour of this party he found out that
this person had a painting on his wall
which cost the amount his house costs
and so he was joking when he was like
that that guy's painting in the house
you think about that like and then you
look at something like Jeff Bezos and
you think oh well he's the richest man
in the world but does he have the most
Fame
no he doesn't does he have the most
Beauty
uh subjective decision does he have the
most
strength or power maybe not and so no
one has the most of everything so when
you measure Yourself by numbers you'll
always be second third fourth fifth in
something I do feel that it's my
responsibility to get my intentions
right and so one of my biggest
visualizations that I do do in the
morning is I so I believe that good
intentions in our life are seeds and bad
intentions are weeds and so what I've
seen weed system weeds and every single
day whatever is getting the followers
it's gonna get the likes with the seeds
and weeds
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah and
I like that yeah I know so I was saying
so what I do is I reflect on my
intentions visually every day
and I think about how many deals am I
taking just because they make me money
or how many videos am I making just
because they get me views or how much
stuff am I doing just for the vanity or
just for the fame or success or what I
think is is going to be good for me like
financially economic like how the how
the default mind is set up to think
about security as opposed to love and
compassion and wanting to change the
world and wanting to make a different
place and I'm constantly battling with
the two so what I'll do every day is
I'll reflect on my intentions I'll
reflect on the deals I've just signed
I'll reflect on uh things I'm being
offered and I'll literally look at each
offer deal whatever it is each item of
thought and I'll say is that a seed or a
weed
and if it's a weed I'll pluck it out
I'll literally visualize myself plucking
out of the The Garden of my mind and
pulling it out and taking it out and if
it's a seed then I'll Water it and I'll
say Okay I want that to grow because I
am doing that for the right intention
when you can be trusted with the small
things and the small moments you get
trusted with more and more and more and
so like it helps to just
in that moment and it's in those painful
moments that you realize how powerful
you are we all know that like you've
really recognize it and and what you
said was beautiful about not rushing
through the pain because and and you
know this example's probably been shared
before but if you have a wound and
you've cut yourself it's like you can't
rush the healing
you can't rush it if you broke your arm
I mean and you've been through so many
bodily injuries you can't rush the
process it's gonna take six weeks
minimum to heal broken and you've got to
sit through that it's hard there's no
injections you can take there's no
videos you can watch there's nothing you
can listen to but our challenge is we
try and rush through the pain rather
than reflect through the pain try to
rush the healing process try to rush the
healing and you can't rush healing and
healing is meant to be slow because it
buys you time it buys you reflection it
gives you so much space to slow down to
slow down and that's what your body's
calling out from this is our emergency
like how many times have you earlier
where you slow down
you slow down and that's when you fall
ill
because guess what your body has been
trying to tell you to slow down when you
feel pain so I write about it and think
like look pain makes you pay attention
yeah that's what Pain's for pains notice
this notice this kiss me look at me it's
crazy it's like a crying baby craving
for attention when a baby's crying you
don't just go I was crying you don't
just go oh yeah we'll just put it in
another room and forget about it right
like you go to it and you find its needs
whereas without pain when something's
painful we're just like oh yeah just
forget about it I'll escape from it I'll
do something else you have to go into
that I'll numb the pain or whatever yeah
but 100 that's that's usually our
responses what can I do to numb this
work more have sex more drink more
whatever is more whatever whatever it is
rather than let me actually become alert
and guess what the pain just gets higher
and higher and higher and higher because
I'm fortunate until it really hurts we
don't stop or you need more and more to
numb it with
so true how many of you spend a lot of
your days multitasking
okay good
so a lot of us spend our time
multitasking now studies show that only
two percent of us are actually able to
multitask
and when most people hear that they're
like yeah I'm in that two percent that's
me right I'm in that two percent uh
you're probably not I'm not because it's
only two percent of the global
population of the world multitasking's a
myth and I find that as spiritual
activists as conscious change makers as
change agents of the world whatever you
want to call yourself
all of us one of the biggest mistakes
we've seen and this was the quote that I
shared and a thought from Martin Luther
King that I've really held close to me
is he said those who love peace
need to learn to organize themselves as
well as those who love war
right those who love peace need to learn
to organize themselves as well as those
who love war I.E people are trying to
build
destruction in the world and
distractions in the world are highly
organized highly focused highly data
oriented highly strategic highly process
driven
and so we have to be the same and when
you spend time with vision or you spend
time with the Mind Valley team you
realize their success is intuitive it is
deep it is full of love but it is also
highly strategic it is also highly
focused and therefore it's effective
and so for me my plea to all of you and
to myself is whatever we're going to do
let's get really strategic about it
let's bring sincerity and strategy
together
let's bring data and dynamism together
let's bring intuition and insight
together
right let's not let's not look beyond
that and think all that stuff's gonna
work out because I intent my intentions
nice
right your intentions are not gonna run
a mile
but it would help you run the marathon
but it's not going to run that mile that
you need to do right now and so for me
intention and action intention and
attention both of them are required and
so my recommendation is whatever your
dream is whatever you're inspired by
whatever you think is going to have a
positive impact on the world bring both
to that right don't settle for one or
the other in 2016 I moved out to New
York so just let me paint a picture of
2016. I moved three jobs
I got married wow I moved country
and I just just started a whole new life
like my life just transformed so we went
to all of that with my wife in one year
and by the way all of that was surprises
the job changes surprises yeah the
country change was a surprise the
marriage was not a surprise apart from
everything else everything was a
surprise now I said I like surprises so
I can roll with it but my point is
that's a lot of transition so much
transition and I felt the burden of
being in a new city where we had no
family we had no friends and my wife who
loves being around her family and no one
understands just how close she is to
them I felt this burden on me that I had
taken away her time with her family and
now she was alone so I was going out to
work and she'd be crying at home and I
was thinking she's got no friends she's
got no support and I know you can relate
to this with moving and relationships
and so much going on and so it's like
I'm dealing with that and guess what six
months later
I have to leave and move on and work on
a new career to build everything myself
and then I'm four months away from being
broke and so on top of all of this I've
now got four months away from being
broke I've got enough money money to
save for four months to pay for rent and
groceries in New York City in New York
City and that's it and guess what even
on top of that I've got 30 days before
my Visa runs out I'm kicked out of the
country so I can't even live here
anymore
so not only have I just got married
moved job three times changed career
again had to move into Obama four months
of being broke and I might get kicked
out in 30 days and my renewal for my
Visa cost fifteen thousand dollars so
that's gonna eat into those four months
I have probably never been under that
much emotional physical and and mental
pressure in my life like genuinely I
felt it and I felt my body change my my
breath was more stressed I would be
breathing faster shorter breaths not
deep breaths heartbeat faster not
working out you get into lazy habits you
start craving junk food sugar you have
energy I'm living in a 500 square foot
apartment with my wife which is which is
Tiny like everything's in that space and
guess what we both work from home so I'm
now sitting at a desk hunched over
trying to figure stuff out she's trying
to cook in the same room like I'm trying
to just just trying to figure out what
to do and I remember the next morning
sending like a hundred emails to people
and just being like this is who I am
this is what I can do how can we serve
and that was the same year that I ended
up meeting you later in that year and
the beginning three months of that
Journey was so stressful like they were
so stressful because I was like What if
I have to move back to London
what am I going to say to her parents I
mean I just took their daughter away
like uh I just got married I've lived in
New York City for six months and my
life's falling apart like you know so
much and I've got all these views but
there's nothing there's nothing
happening here you also you also I mean
at this time you're also growing so much
how are you able to create and reach
this impact with your videos as that's
growing while you're under so much
stress and uncertainty and I stopped a
bit at that time like things slowed down
hard like things slowed down I remember
I wasn't creating as much as I was
because I don't enjoy creating from
stress or pressure and I don't think you
can really create something from stress
and pressure so we really slow down at
that time and when I was creating I was
creating from a place of recognizing
that I could share what I had learned
and what I had grown in so far so
anything I was sharing was like this is
what I've learned so far so that was the
biggest pain that I've been through in
the last seven years for sure and all I
can say is that I remember coming home
to my wife knowing that this was going
to be the truth and I came and I said to
her I said to her I guarantee you this
is gonna be the best thing that ever
happened to us what the pain the pain I
said that to the night I came home and
then she arrived I literally came on my
electronics this is the scenario
and I just want you to know that I
guarantee to you this is the best thing
that's ever going to happen to us and I
said to them this is this is a monk
statement that we used to repeat I said
to I'm just not going to judge the
moment don't judge the moment because
what we do is we try to label moments as
good or bad and when you label a moment
as bad it now does not have the
opportunity to become good I'll give an
example if I go I don't like this book
this book's bad right and I don't know
but if I say that guess what I will
never pick it up and recognize the value
that's inside of it because you've
labeled it yes and we label stuff like
we label oh that restaurant's bad
but when you label them that person's
bad now you can't learn from that person
oh a great one that's a really good one
as soon as you start labeling people or
anything as good or bad you limit it you
stop it from being something else and
here's the truth every moment can evolve
into being anything if you give it the
opportunity to right but as soon as you
say it's got no value anymore you lose
it and so for me I had to say to myself
don't judge the moment and I'd keep
repeating that don't judge where you're
at don't judge what's happening yeah
don't judge it as negative don't don't
just start saying it's negative because
that's what we've all been in positions
where a gift turned into a curse and a
curse turned into a gift true right our
dreams came true and it would end up not
being what we wanted exactly it fell
apart and it led us into the our Dream
Tony why is it that so many people that
win the lottery yeah go broke yeah gifts
can turn into cuss is too true but
because we label them as the best moment
in our life or the worst moment in their
life whereas when you approach things to
neutrality and just what you have on the
table you can be like okay what am I
going to do next how have you related to
deep spirit learnings
and at the same time being happy and
content in the material world without
going crazy
interesting question
I think that's this point of spiritual
training
so it's like when we're when we're
immature in our spiritual learning we're
just starting out
when you first learned the first
everyone remember the first time they
learned something and they're like I'm
never talking to my family ever again
right it's like because because you
learn a little bit and you go oh my god
I've been doing it all wrong
and now I can't talk to that person I
can't ever go to that event again and
you start making all these big decisions
based on something small that you've
learned
and so I think in the beginning of our
Lives because to protect ourselves which
is a very normal desire and very good
and very human we think okay I need to
take care of this so now I'm going to
shut out from all of this but as we grow
we realize we can give more back
and so one of the ways I've always
thought about it is
if you look at the ocean and you see
someone drowning
you want to help them
but if you go in too soon and you're not
strong enough it's likely that you're
going to get pulled in
and at that point it's easier to shout
out to a lifeguard who can come along
who's trained who's disciplined who's
committed who can go and make a
difference
and so for me in my life I'm always
looking at if I can't bring someone up
I'm not going to spend time with them if
they're going to pull me down
and it's drawing that line for me
so if I've been ever scared about my
spiritual rather than putting them down
and going oh I'm not spending time with
them because I'm putting them down if I
can't lift them up then I'm going to
protect myself by not being dragged down
but if I can pull them up if I can lift
them up
then that's when I'm able to go into
that space and make an impact to make a
difference and that line has really
helped me not go crazy because I know
I'm not doing it based on a judgment of
them I'm reflecting on my own abilities
and flaws and and the difference I can
make and I'm taking a taking a stance
it's like someone asked me the other day
what is a complaint and when we're
talking about litter
a complaint is you see a piece of trash
on the floor and you go oh la is so
dirty
you've removed the agency that you can
have an impact on that
a statement is oh LA's a bit dirty
there's trash and floor I'm gonna pick
that up and throw it away right taking
that responsibility so when we're
irresponsible in our spiritual lives we
judge everyone and judge everything
and we mature we start looking at
through compassion empathy and
connection and recognize we were just
there a few years ago
and that's the biggest anchor in my life
is recognizing that I was addicted to
and still I'm in different ways
things that I don't believe are good for
me spiritually and I was that I was that
guy I was that kid you know and it's
taken a journey and someone had to
believe in me someone had to invest in
me someone had to reach their hand
without being forced in and pull me out
and so that allows me to continue to
operate in the world I hope that answers
your question because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
another amazing Jay Shetty video check
it out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there